[Music]
two words
snail slime
snail slime
[Music]
snails love their own slime which is
actually their mucus it helps them defy
gravity and move at a snail's pace badly
shiny but humans also love snail slime
for its nutrient-rich properties this
began thousands of years ago when
ancient romans and greeks gave snails
free reign to roam their faces no more
redness no more wrinkles for our
classical ancestors multi-person
that is kind of off topic simone but now
that you're here i think we should segue
to your introduction
he's being modest simone is an inventor
and a snail savior before he invented
his snail slime extraction machine the
only way to collect mass quantities of
snail slime resulted in the snail's
death
not anymore
[Music]
[Music]
we begin
in the fields
after munching for 14 months snails are
plucked
washed and brought to simone's machine
the mueller one
sidebar snails secrete slime for three
reasons to move out of stress
and for pleasure
simone calls his machine a spa for
snails because it pleasures them with a
secret spray to the point that they
secrete a lot of slime inundation
if you don't talk metric i'll translate
that's as much as seven pounds of slime
from one batch
after that the slime is extracted
dehydrated rehydrated and then refined
here for use in cosmetics
here it is being bottled and then it's
off to your face
[Music]
slime in the world simone if being bold
is wrong
we don't want to be right
[Music]
you